the focus of this video is going to be
on sequences which you have hopefully
already seen if you don't know what a
sequence is I encourage you to review
those videos on Khan Academy but we're
going to focus on how we can generate
the same sequence with different
functions that have different domains so
let's just start with an example
sequence let's say we have a sequence
it's a six you could call that the first
term some people would call that the
zeroth term six and then if that's the
first term the second term is now a 12
then a 24 then a 48 and so on and so
forth and as we'll see there's multiple
function definitions that could create
the sequence one way to think about it
is this is 6 times 1 this is 6 times 2
this is 6 times 4 this is 6 times 8 so
it looks like each term is 6 times a
power of 2 let me make that clear this
one right over here is 6 times 2 to the
0 that's 6 times 1 this one over here is
6 times 2 to the first this one over
here is 6 times 2 squared 6 times 4 this
right over here is 6 times 2 to the
third and so one way to view this is if
you view this as the zeroth term we
could define a function let's call it a
of n where n is referring to our index
or which term in the sequence and it's
equal to 6 times 2 6 times 2 to the N
where n starts at 0 and then it keeps
incrementing by 1 so it's really all
integers greater than or equal to 0 it's
very important to specify that domain
where where n where n is an integer
integer and n is greater than or equal
to 0 you could see what happens if n is
not an integer if you tried
put a 1.5 year or something like that
then you're not going to get one of the
terms in the sequence and if we don't
start at zero if we started at one then
this would be the first term of the
sequences which is not what we want we
want to generate the sequence that I
originally wrote down and I've obviously
if you started at N equals negative 1
then you're going to get a different
value for your first term so this is one
way to to essentially define or to
create a function which generates this
sequence but as we'll see there are
other ways to do it for example let me
do another one and I'll do it another
color let's say I have B of N and let's
say I want to instead of making instead
of saying okay I'm gonna start at N
equals zero and you could kind of view
this as the zero theorem I want to start
at N equals one so what you could do is
is when you input a 1 this essentially
becomes a zero how do I do that well I
just subtract one from it so I could say
six times two to the N minus one power
where n is an integer integer and n is
greater than or equal to 1 notice now
when we put N equals 1 in here and we
could maybe call this the first term we
want to generate a 6 so what happens 1
minus 1 we get that zeroth power that we
want right over there and so 6 times 2
to the 0 is indeed 6 then when n is
equal to 2 it's 6 times 2 to the 2 minus
1 which is just 2 to the first power so
it's just become 6 times 2 which is
equal to 12 so notice these are
different function definitions with
different domains but they're generating
the exact same sequence we could also do
it recursively and we've seen this in
other videos we can define a function
recursively we could say all right look
it looks like each of these each of
these terms in our sequence is twice the
previous term so we could if we want a
recursive definition for the sequence we
can define the first term or in this
case we could say the zeroth term if we
want to start at N equals 0 T of 0 is
two-six and then we could say t of n is
equal to two times T of n minus one T of
n minus one and then this is going to be
this is going to be four or maybe I'll
write it this way
where n is an integer and n is greater
than or equal to zero this would also
generate the sequence when you put N
equals zero here you'll get that term
when you get N equals 1 T of 1 is going
to be 2 times T of 1 minus 1 T of 0 in
that case it would be T of it would be 2
times T of 0 is 6 so 2 times 6 it would
get you 12 now if you wanted it so that
it generates the 6 when N equals 1 you
could do it this way let me you could
write it actually maybe I should have
kept all of that right so I'm gonna have
to rewrite all of that but you could
write it this way instead of saying T of
0 is equal to 6
we could write T of 1 is equal to 6 but
now I would have to write a different
domain where and still has to be an
integer n is an integer and now instead
of saying n is greater than or equal to
0 now n is greater than or equal to 1 so
hopefully this video hits the point home
that there's multiple ways either with a
traditional I guess you say explicit
function or a recursive function like
this and even in either of those cases
you could have different domains and
different function definitions that
generate the same sequence but you
really have to think about the domain